[Musique]
alors au moment où les la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre préoccupe quand même comme
jamais les employeurs canadiens avec
plus de 800 mhz et le poste vacant au
pays quatre des cinq partis présents à
la chambre des communes font des
propositions pour y remédier dans leur
plateforme électorale
notre séance du vendredi diane gabrielle
tremblay diane gabrielle tremblay voilà
professeur à l'école des sciences de
l'administration de l'université téluq
et véronique proulx pdg des
manufacturiers et exportateurs du québec
bonsoir
alors véronique peau est ce qu'elle est
partie pour vous propose de régler ce
fameux problème de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
lorsqu'on a vu jusqu'à présent la
réponse est non alors on propose
différentes mesures mais des mesures qui
sont ciblés des mesures qui auront très
peu d'impact pour contrer la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre et c'est quand même
intéressant de voir que certains partis
parti libéral partis conservateurs
promettent de créer des milliers
d'emplois et nous ce qu'on dit on n'a
pas besoin qui créent les emplois on a
besoin qu'ils nous donnent des gens
puissent travailler dans les usines dans
les bureaux et dans tous les secteurs
économiques est ce que quand même des
idées diane gabrielle tremblay par
exemple des idées peut-être intéressante
que vous avez vus entendus jusqu'à
maintenant dans la campagne électorale à
propos de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
oui tout à fait chanter les éléments de
solution sont leurs on les retrouve la
question c'est voilà ce que ce sera mise
en oeuvre et comment je pense que les on
parle beaucoup de formations
professionnelles il ya des gens et les
jeunes notamment mais aussi d'autres
personnes des migrants qui n'ont pas
toujours informations requises donc on
parle de formation professionnelle on ne
parle peut-être pas suffisamment de
l'augmentation des salaires quand on dit
on la lui dise difficultés à avoir des
salariés parfois c'est justement parce
que les salaires vont c'est l'hôtellerie
la restauration tout ça ça un peu
augmenté mais parfois c'est un petit peu
faible donc les gens sont moins
intéressés les services de garde ou un
programme de garderies nationale et
canadiennes je pense de très important
pour les femmes donc il ya quand même
des idées qui sont là mais il faudra
voir est ce que ce sera effectivement
mis de l'avant exactement c'est quelles
sont vos solutions véronique trop
écouter pour nous la première solution
et qui a été peu discuté jusqu'à présent
c'est l'immigration alors j'entends les
commentaires qui ont été faits notamment
par rapport aux salaires j'ai envie de
dire que le bassin de travailleurs
présentement il n'est pas assez grand
une entreprise qui recrute c'est comme
c'est le péché dans un live et diop
personne c'est particulièrement vrai
dans les régions du québec où le taux de
chômage est plutôt plutôt bas plutôt
faible en fait alors les migrations pour
nous c'est vraiment une plaque tournante
il faut aussi les seuils d'immigration
pour pouvoir répondre aux postes vacants
mais aussi grossir l'économie par faire
croître l'économie plus tôt au cours des
prochaines années c'est clair qu'il faut
attirer davantage de femmes les jeunes
les autochtones et immigrants également
donc ça prend davantage de mesures
prêtes attractif la formation pour nous
c'est essentiel mais porte n'importe
quelle formation lorsqu'on parle du
secteur manufacturier
on a besoin de plus de formations
courtes plus de formation en entreprise
pour répondre aux besoins du marché du
travail ok donc formation c'est
intéressant immigration sur
l'immigration madame tremblay diane
tremblay j'oublie toujours le nom que
vous avez dans le diane gabrielle
comment rappeler
on a on parle d'immigrants d'immigrants
économiques
est ce que est ce que c'est la solution
est ce qu'on peut en accueillir
davantage en intégrer davantage pour
vous est ce que c'est une vraie bonne
solution je pense que la question vous
l'avez mentionné il ya l'intégration
c'est bien de les faire venir mais après
ce qu'on les intègre et moi j'avais
envie je pense qu'on retrouve sa mère
dans la plateforme de madame croule
les étudiants étrangers nous on en forme
des étudiants d'université à l'école de
technologie supérieure partout et
malheureusement dans beaucoup de cas ils
ne peuvent pas rester c'est très longue
et très complexe pour qu'ils puissent
rester alors ils se découragent ils
partent ailleurs bondi québec qui vont
aller dans votre province parfois ils
retournent carrément chez eux en france
en angleterre par tous donc je pense que
déjà ces personnes là qui sont bien
intégrés au québec au canada il faut des
faudrait déjà conservé ces personnes là
non seulement elles sont bien formés
mais en plus elles connaissent la
culture des organisations certaine aux
étudiants font des stages en entreprise
je trouve que vraiment de ce côté là
c'est vrai qu'il faudrait déjà les
retenir ou si les travailleurs
vieillissants avant d'aller du côté de
l'immigration oui c'est très bien mais
on a quand même des travailleurs
vieillissants qui sont déjà formés alors
parfois ces personnes leur voudrais
rester avec des aménagements quatre
jours semaine pour télétravail sera plus
populaires certainement mais parfois les
entreprises refusent ses modalités la
qui ferait que ces gens là extraits en
emplois plus longtemps alors qui est
venue l'idée d'accorder un crédit
d'impôt aux 65 ans et plus par exemple
je pense que oui je pense que cette
dimension effectivement financière pour
certaines personnes de 65 ans et plus à
jour pour beaucoup d'autres c'est
l'organisation du travail la flexibilité
des horaires faire des horaires moins
longs parce que on pense à des
professionnels ou d'autres qui sont
devenus cadres qui font des horaires
plus longs et qui disent bien moins 65
ans je resterai jusqu'à 70 mais je ne
veux pas faire soixante dix heures par
semaine donc je crois qu'il ya des
choses de ce côté les mots les
recherches que j'ai menées mais tu es
vraiment de l'avant ces solutions là qui
ont signé avec l'organisation du travail
parfois les entreprises sont un petit
peu rigide sur ce plan là vous en
pensez-quoi véronique mais en fait je
pense qu'effectivement on pourrait
certainement accueillir davantage de
travailleurs expérimentés en secteur
manufacturier on est prêt pour la
plupart à faire les aménagements
nécessaires pour les accueillir le jour
trois jours sur les horaires flexibles
l'est présentement les mesures qui sont
en place et même avec les crédits
d'impôts que propose le même temps parce
que parti libéral lorsqu'on le cumul au
crédit d'impôt provincial on part on
parle d'environ 4000 par année je ne
pense pas que ce soit suffisant
malheureusement pour inciter ceux qui
ont déjà pris la retraite à revenir sur
le marché du travail donc quand je
parlais de mesures timides c'est l'une
d'entrés elles à prendre des mesures qui
ont beaucoup plus d'impact est-ce que je
peux revenir oui il revenait allez-y
j'avais venir sur les étudiants
étrangers et je m'en serais tout à fait
c'est des gens qui sont déjà ici qu'on
pourrait intégrer davantage la même
chose que les travailleurs étrangers
temporaires on vient tout juste de
compléter une tournée de consultation
partout à travers le québec par secteur
manufacturier on accueille beaucoup de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires les
manufacturiers veulent les garder
voudrait qu'il peut s'installer en
région la question des délais c'est
effectivement vrai les délais sont
beaucoup trop longs que pas eu
d'engagement encore d'aucun parti à
réduire les délais de façon ferme et
effectivement après à capacité d'accueil
et d'intégration donc son propre de
places en garderies des écoles du
logement mais servette essentiel de
passer par cette régionalisation
admiration la sadur d'augmenter notre
capacité d'accueil en région si on veut
maintenir nos entreprises
manufacturières et dans les autres
secteurs d'activités aussi s comprend
différentes régions est ce que programme
national de garderies pourrait aider
massivement à calmer la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
moi je pense que c'est majeur on a vu au
québec quant à nous on a traduit sa au
québec clairement ça et des boucles
entrée sur un marché du travail on
regarde le coût des garderies à toronto
à vancouver c'est complètement effarant
pour des femmes qui travaillent dans les
secteurs des services dans la
manufacture et c'est peut-être autre
chose des salaires sont meilleurs mais
y'a pas nécessairement toujours autant
de femmes surtout dans les bons salaires
donc les femmes peuvent avoir de la
difficulté à chercher un emploi est en
fait à demeurer sur le marché du travail
compte tenu des frais très important
pour les services de garde donc moi je
pense que c'est vraiment quelque chose
de majeur à travers le canada quand je
rencontre des collègues des gens partout
on nous dit bah oui au québec c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très
intéressant et on avait vu l'impact tout
de suite donc france c'est vraiment un
élément il y en a tellement qu'on ne
pouvait pas aborder mais que je retrouve
un peu les pieds là c'est la question de
la transition numérique alors c'est vrai
que ça aussi les travailleurs
vieillissants parfois on était allé fort
mais on se dit ils ne vont pas rester en
entreprise c'est faux si on les forme
c'est des travailleurs qui sont très
loyaux aussi loyaux voire plus parfois
même que les jeunes donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment regarder de ce côté là nos
pme doivent faire une transition
numérique l'intelligence armée célèbre
bien des défis mais je pense qu'il faut
regarder de ce côté là l'hostis à des
défis un peu d'éthique là avec
l'intelligence artificielle de diversité
ou si des profils ok là une piste de
solution parfait la pcr vers une expo
souvent au banc des accusés depuis des
semaines et ce qu'il faut l'abolir
mais il faut certainement à une
transition c'est à dire qu'il faut
amener les travailleurs qui sont au
chômage présentement qui bénéficient de
la clpc heureux pour les amener à
transiter par un marché du travail pour
mener les mets en place des incitatifs
pour favoriser sur le retour au travail
là que ça soit la formation d'autres
mesures la pcu la pcr eux ont eu leur
raison d'être est présentement au québec
on parle de du 118 218 le poste vacant
c'est énorme pour n'était pas normal
qu'on ait encore autant de chômeurs dont
faut vraiment changer la façon de faire
la promo amener ces gens-là réintégrer
le marché du travail le plus vite
possible bon ben c'est très bien merci
on a fait un beau tour de piste on a
abordé plusieurs sujets vous avez des
bonnes solutions merci on vous écoute
vers des produits en gabriel tremblay
merci beaucoup merci aussi bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit